in this lesson we're going to talk about
absolute value so this is something that
they test on the act
and the important thing to know about
absolute value is that you want to treat
the absolute value bars just like you
would print parentheses right you want
to do that part first
what's inside and then whatever you get
for your answer
the final result is going to be positive
so in this case you can see the absolute
value of negative three is going to be
positive three the absolute value of
positive three will also be positive
three so you don't wanna you don't wanna
think that it's the opposite you just
want to think do the operation inside
the absolute value bars
the final result is going to be positive
okay
here's a common mistake that sometimes
students will make they'll see like you
know the absolute value of 2x minus 3
and they'll say oh i have to make this
positive i'm going to make this plus 3.
you don't want to make that mistake you
just want to do the operation here first
and then
your final answer will be a positive
value so let's do a couple examples here
you can pause the video and try these on
your own and we'll go through them so
this first one i'm going to just work
from the inside out right so 4 times
negative 2 is a negative 8.
okay
we've got a negative 5 times a negative
1 is actually a positive 5. a negative 8
plus 5 is negative 3
okay and then the absolute value of
negative 3 is positive 3.
okay now in this example the absolute
value of negative 2 is positive 2 okay
multiply by negative 3.
the absolute value of positive 2 is 2
times 4 is 8
negative 3 times 2 is negative 6
and negative 6 plus 8 is positive 2. so
you can see i'm basically following the
order of operations i'm treating the
absolute values like parentheses doing
that operation
there's no exponents we go to
multiplication division then lastly
addition subtraction so this is a brief
review of just how to work with absolute
values i'll see you in the next lesson